hey folks it's Friday again you're doing
another movie retrospective that's right
guess what we're doing this time we're
gonna do one called High Plains Drifter
which is kind of a Western but also kind
of a horror movie yeah
a lot of people don't know that this is
actually a paranormal Western yeah it's
like yeah it's more like a revenant as
demonic force comes back to wreak
vengeance and punish a town that's done
done a good man wrong yeah good flick I
remember when I first saw it when I was
a kid I really didn't catch the whole
supernatural aspect when I was a kid but
when I got older I saw it especially
like in the soundtrack sometimes weird
stuff would happen like wait a minute
how did Clint survive that and there'd
be this weird ghostly music going on in
the background yeah yeah powers going on
it's funny because I mean I probably saw
this when I was a kid too because you
know my my dad and my grandfather were
really into westerns I'm not super into
Western it's like I like some of them I
like some of it but um I had seen this
one when I was a kid and it didn't
really register at the time that this
was like a paranormal like a ghost story
essentially but then when I saw it again
when I was older I'm like Oh duh it's
like it seems super obvious yeah it
wasn't back then though yeah I guess not
and my stepdad this is one of his
favorite movies he saw it many times
over and he didn't get it yeah I told
him so you realize that that guy is the
marshal come back he's like really and I
showed him where it was you know in the
very end
yeah we're Mordechai never did tell me
your name yes yes I did you know if you
know what my name yeah and he was saying
that as he was putting the grave up over
the sheriff who was you know buried it
without seams really yeah and the
symbolism is very obvious now yeah just
don't expect it from a Western yeah it's
kind of a strange move and like I said
it's interesting because you know we've
seen it several times since then cuz you
bought it on blu-ray or DVD is actually
DVD I got to get a blu-ray and like I
said I'm not a huge fan of westerns in
general
I have liked a lot of them in there and
I've liked a lot of horror movie style
you know or western style horror movies
you know they have made them before so I
do kind of like that type of thing but
it's interesting that this movie turns
up on a lot of horror movie review sites
I noticed so it's not totally weird that
we're just you know I'm also getting way
off into Sergio Leone movies I'm aware
yeah you said that he's under Sergio
Leone yeah I mean last couple months I'm
just starting to realize now you know we
really wasn't hip to the whole Western
thing and especially not the spaghetti
western thing yeah and I didn't realize
that Sergio Leone actually set the new
standard for what a Western should be
well because that was hugely influential
on Clint Eastwood's movie yeah all the
Clint Eastwood's badass movies like this
one this is the first one he did he
directed on is it the first Western
first question he directed on his own
this is a spaghetti western even though
it's American made yeah it's got that
same edit that same tone it's that same
kind of dystopian view of the West it's
cool it's really cool because it
traditionally what a Western was in
American you know cinematic history a
Western was a movie that clear had clear
boundaries between black and white good
and evil black hat white house black hat
white hat
they were very predictable very
formulaic there was a lot of dialogue
and a lot of talking not a whole lot of
action they were like an episode of
bonanza they were boring and they got
boring as they win I didn't like them
because that's a by the time the 60s had
rolled around 64 you know with Sergio
Leone they had become Oh stale genre
yeah the United States only made a
couple of them a year but the new way of
doing it the spaghetti western style way
of doing it actually breathe life back
into the genre well it was out that you
never would had Unforgiven and some of
these other ones are really good
introduced moral ambiguity realism
realism and also like a stylishness that
I don't think had really I mean you know
what I mean that the
no the very um you know these big like
long close-ups and stuff like that like
that are kind of a hallmark of Clint
Eastwood movies I mean he got that
directly from Sergio Leone yeah very
much and you know and he'll will tell
you that because you know Clint Eastwood
had starred in a lot of Sergio Leone's
movies obviously the man with no name
mmm trilogy or whatever we're actually
gonna probably do that at some point
without a mansion it you know it's it's
important in in cinema history right and
so at this stage Clint really liked that
style and he's like what he wanted to do
when himself now he had only directed
one other movie before this and it
wasn't a Western it was actually a
thriller play misty for me which I
actually recommend if you haven't seen
it it's a you know kind of a kind of
fatal attraction type story have you
ever seen it
no you haven't seen play misty for me
yeah oh it's good no go yeah it's kind
of like a feel like a like a crazy fan
like I think he's like a radio DJ I
haven't seen in a long time but he's
like a radio DJ and she's like this
crazed fan that like obsessed by having
said you're like Eastwood's really big
movies yeah you know the western ones
and maybe like Firefox yeah and then we
saw the new one you know the yeah
alright yeah I like that even though
like I said he looks like the
Cryptkeeper only yeah he's old now but
he's like 400 years old he was old when
he did this and this was done when I was
3 years old
yeah I was one when this movie came out
this came out in 1973 like I said this
was his first Western now it was
actually written by Ernest ty demon who
is probably best known for writing the
shaft novels and doing the adaptations
of shaft hey they're remaking shaft I
just saw the trailer it really look good
I'm excited yeah I wanna see I'm super
excited
I loved the shaft it looks funny but
yeah so I don't like the expendables
yeah you know it looks like something
where he's like passing the torch amps
camps and secret agents so it's gotta be
good you know it's gotta be good yeah
everybody loves pimps come to say you
see blaxploitation but yeah but yeah so
he was known for writing the shaft
novels and he also later won an Oscar
for writing the French Connection
so the guy that wrote this no slouch now
originally here's the interesting thing
that I thought
what's really interesting now the
original in you know we've had we've had
it back and forth about how much we're
gonna spoil about particular movies some
of them we don't want to like when we
did the review for big man Japan I said
you know this only came out in 2007
probably a lot of people haven't seen it
because it's a little bit obscure and I
said and I think that's the kind of
movie where it's better if you go into
it not not knowing what to expect yeah
but I feel like this movie is such kind
of a part of the cultural landscape and
it came out so long ago that I don't
think we're gonna hurt anything by it
spoiling anything but what I was gonna
say is that the original version of the
script actually had because the whole
story involves there's this little town
called Lago and you know it's just on
the shores of this lake it's like out in
the middle of nowhere they really built
this town for the moon they did it's a
real town what universe all had like
bugged Clint Eastwood they're like well
why don't you shoot it on the back lot
and he's like no I don't want to do that
I want to shoot on location it looks
real and he drove around like Nevada and
Oregon and [ __ ] like looking for a place
to film and he couldn't find any place
and then finally he found this one place
and I think it's mono lake or Mono Lake
in California and he just built this
little bitty town like just on the edge
of this lake kind of out in the middle
of nowhere and he built the entire town
outside exteriors and interiors so he
could film the whole thing on location
yeah took six weeks came in under budget
and it was done like two days before I
was supposed to be done it's a it's a
movie classic it really is and like I
said it's it's there's something like
really kind of spooky about it here's
the thing like Clint Eastwood he does
have a name like I said he's this is
almost like a continuation his name at
the end yeah this is almost like a
continuation of his man with no name
yeah type presence that were like you
know Fistful of Dollars and good bad the
ugly and all those kind of movies
that's kind of the same type of deal
that he's doing here he rides into this
town called Lago and all of the
townspeople in Lago you come to discover
[ __ ]
art yeah most of my [ __ ] for all but
like two of them
I think are just straight-up all about
status and money and their own their own
well-being they're not in there cowards
yeah
bad bad cowards he shows up and the
first thing they do is they attack him
and he kills like three or four of them
yeah I think he kills like 3d he's just
like look he just rides into town on his
pale horse ilysm and he rides in he's
like hey he wants a shave in a bath or
whatever yeah these three douche hats
like come in like hey you good owner
Burton he's just like Kapow Kapow
yeah you get gunned him down and this
imp read everyone's like her the town
hussy bumps into him and then starts
cussing him out like hey there's no need
for this it's just need for what is if
you wanted to get acquainted and you
just could've done it another oh I would
have nothing to do with you this and
then this animal no no no no not so
what's he do he rapes her he rapes a
right rib since she liked it and yeah
and as soon as you see this happen
you're gonna [ __ ] cut a movie in because
you don't really know what the hell's
going on
yeah but that's what I like about this
movie as well like yeah this High Plains
Drifter this drifter from a higher plane
and I'm gonna show you says High Plains
it's a red eye with him riding out of it
okay
he is a drifter from a higher plane okay
get it get it alright so he knows all
these people he knows all their foibles
and he knows all their sins and it turns
out what he is he's basically kind of
like a demonic force back from the grave
to punish these people in turn take this
town to hell yeah punish all these evil
people and then to save the souls of the
good note which there was like a couple
no there's a two Mexican workers Oh more
than why there's the the guy's wife that
owns the hotel hotel Belding or buzz
about it that's what I mean okay so for
people that's about it yeah the rest
were hoping
everyone else yes right and then you
find out where this drifter who this
drifter from a higher plane is and you
know when you're about 30 minutes into
it they show you what had happened in
the past the old sheriff got whipped to
death by some hired guns
yeah the town hired these hired guns to
whip the sheriff to death he found out
eventually find out the reason why they
hired these guns to whip the sheriff to
death is because the sheriff found out
that the mine and the the mining company
that was keeping this town growing that
that mine was on government property and
they technically were exactly were
supposed to be mining and the sheriff
gonna do the right thing and tell the
government that the mind that hey the
mine was on it was on public land or on
government property they couldn't be
mining on they killed him yeah and are
they hired hired guns to kill him there
was a creeper and as bad as they were
the dudes that they hired to kill the
sheriff they [ __ ] them over yeah they
basically turned on him and made him go
to prison exactly yeah and so what's
happening is the the drifter from the
higher plane is showing up into town or
out the time these guys are getting out
of prison and are coming back they're
coming back to this town for revenge all
right
and after he guns those dudes down they
say you got to help us cuz these guys
are coming and we can't defend ourselves
and he's like yeah he's gonna defend
yourself yeah I mean you got all these
people they hire him to protect the town
so the first thing he does he raises a
militia he tries to train them to defend
the town does all kinds of stuff
he makes it part of the deal was is he
has an unlimited spending budget yeah he
basically they basically offer him he's
like whatever you want ever you want and
he takes everything 500 gallons of red
paint and paints the entire town red he
hasn't take down people's barns and make
picnic tables because they're gonna be
picnicking when the bad guys showed up
he even starts screwing all their wives
yeah that's how cowardly are they
wanting to stand up for their own women
yeah okay so he makes everyone out of
their hotel sir
can live in the hotel all by himself the
basic moral of this story is is that
being a coward is not a virtue
all right yeah being a coward would
actually caused you to do evil like not
stand up for your wife or to sell people
out and then well because they all stood
by watching tomorrow you'll get murdered
like only one or two people stood up and
go hey this is [ __ ] up what are you
doing nobody else did that everyone just
stood there and watched now I should
note since we're talking about that the
original draft of the script like I said
that was written by Ernest tiny'mon he
said he got the idea from the very
famous kitty Genovese murder that
happened in the 60s and in New York City
where well okay the story goes I think
it happened in 1964 where she was
walking home to her apartment building
and like some dude jumped on her and
started sent stabbed her to death and
the story goes that 38 witnesses saw it
but no one did anything to help her and
nobody called the police blah blah blah
so that kind of went into the cultural
consciousness so he kind of was like I
wanted to write a story about someone
getting killed in the middle of town and
everyone just sanding around watching it
and not doing anything I should note
that the kitty Genovese see murder
later on they did discover that there
weren't actually that many witnesses
nobody saw the whole thing happened a
couple people did call the police one
person actually did go out there and
help her [ __ ] like that so you know the
the story that went around about the
murder is not entirely accurate but
that's where he got the idea from yeah
so he was kind of exploring the idea of
who was it that said that you know all
it takes for evil to take root is like
for a good minute nothing right that's
basically so that's basically the idea
that this movie is exploring and Clint
Eastwood playing quote-unquote the
stranger that's just what they call him
in the credits where he's kind of like I
would call him a revenant yeah um he's
they don't come out like he seems like a
man and everything like that but to
touch him he's mortal yeah he's solid
he's solid but he's you can't kill him
doesn't seem to be he comes across as
like a little bit of a supernatural
verse because he comes out of some
situations that that would have killed
somebody right he also by lo
hated at one time did yeah I didn't like
exploit wasn't explicit yeah but you
were like well how did he get out of
there you were like yeah he didn't have
time he snuck into his bedroom tried to
club him and definitely was in bed and
they were clubbing something but he
wasn't in there he didn't have time to
get out of there and he was outside with
a stick of dynamite blew him up yeah and
they played that blue wait a ghostly
yeah there's like how the hell he get
outside is like every time yeah he does
some like spooky [ __ ]
he's a revenant you know which is
someone who's come back from the dead to
wreak revenge you had the crow yeah okay
but there's also kind of like it this is
not a Christian thing and this is this
kind of reminds me more of kind of like
the when we have some Muslim subscribers
this is almost kind of like the Islamic
concept of a demon or a devil in Islam
demons and Devils are creations of God
they can't disobey God so even though
demons and Devils do evil they're doing
evil to support God's work like for a
greater purpose they're working for God
that seems to be the case that seems to
be the case in this cuz he's doing evil
things but it's working out it's
actually good is coming from it and
there's a scene where the priest comes
in who was kind of a corrupt priest he
goes listen brother you can't kick all
these people out of the hotel because
I'm not your brother
yeah you know because we can't keep we
cause we are all God's children's and
brothers and sisters you know you can't
kick all these people out because these
people are all your brothers and sisters
and yeah he goes well you take them you
take them in your house he turns around
he goes uh ladies and gentlemen don't
worry you're all can stay with us and it
won't cost you any more than what it
cost you in normal hotel rates right
yeah that revenant went what you know
expected thank you for heard anything
yeah so you know what one subscriber
comes to mind that you know you know
who's living in an Islamic country I'd
actually like him to see this and I'd
like him to get back with me telling me
what he thought of this movie he'd
probably love this movie but to me it
kind of had the Islamic flavor of what
demon is because it hasn't really match
up with Christian mythos yeah it's
almost kind of like because really what
Clint Eastwood's role is he like rolls
up in a town and like I said it's very
um in you know it's very instructive
that at the very beginning of the movie
the very first shot of the movie is
Clint Eastwood on his horse like off in
the distance like appearing out of the
haze yeah he just was like be like music
like so he's obviously yeah not a human
and at the end of the movie when they
show with the the marshal that they
whipped to death finally they gave him a
headstone one of the characters says it
says that if you bury man without a
headstone his soul can't rest yeah in
Iran Mordechai who's a dwarf who was the
only one of the only good men in town he
couldn't stop the killing you know to me
but he when you see the movie you see
what if he was seeing I'm talking about
he find the erecta headstone and as the
stranger rides off into the distance he
gets smaller and smaller and smaller and
it goes towards the headstone and then
goes behind it you go like he's going
back to the grave yeah it's quite a cool
scene yeah because that was the whole
point because what you're meant to think
like I said now the original version of
the script had the marshal who is
whipped to death by the townspeople or
by the dudes that the townspeople hired
he's actually played by the guy that was
Clint Eastwood's
stunt man so he looks very much like
Clint Eastwood yeah you think is that
Eastwood or kind of but it yes so it
could almost looks exactly like him but
not quite but that's why cuz that's it's
done makes sense if the revenant comes
back he can't look exactly like the old
marshal they're like man where are you
good
what kind of like in the original
version of the script the stranger was
supposed to be the marshal's brother
okay but Clint Eastwood liked the idea
of making natural yeah making him like
the ghost of you live in it it's a lot
better making it like allegorical yeah
if you like the crow that's basically
what you're doing yes
wanted to do and so that's why he he put
in all this stuff about like we have to
paint every building in the town red and
he can he renamed lago have never made
renamed it hell yeah there's like
there's a scene where after after the
stranger pates he'll over the side and
and and he had the whole town out there
work he tells him to go back and they
all start going back to town and you see
it the way it's shot they're all going
to the sign of hell like fire ball going
to hell and the only one that wasn't
going to hell was little little loves
it's Mordecai Mordecai was just walking
straight ahead yeah so your show when
you're right now that you sent in all
these people to hell except Mordecai
yeah and like I'm saying this this
revenant is doing evil things including
up to rape and women okay yeah he does
it a couple that in some ways but it's
for the good which that's not a normal
Western value you know almost that's
more like something you find in Islam
and now for that because of this John
Wayne hated this movie he really [ __ ]
hated this movie
just goes to show you what the
difference to nanu western was that was
basically like I'm a spaghetti western
Sergio Leone and what the old westerns
Oh Mike I said I feel like a lot of
movies break in the late sixties and
seventies of Vietnam um a lot of movies
in the 70s started to go toward this
ambiguous morality type thing and I
think a lot of older filmmakers in
Hollywood and particularly John Wayne
and stuff like that didn't really like
that because I think they liked the very
clear-cut Western it's like these are
the good guys these are the bad guys but
after Vietnam happened and you know all
of that I don't really think you could
get away with that anymore it just
seemed too simplistic so I can I can
understand how you would call this
ambiguous morality yeah
based upon Western traditions yeah but I
look at it and I go no it's just
alternate reality it is yeah what it is
is it's it's a person it is or it's a
force of nature or you know or on enter
or what do you call it a supernatural
force
punishing evil yeah that's what it's
doing he's not punishing evil with love
and flowers it's punishing them with
pain suffering and death because he
really seemed as yes you see it's kind
of biblical in a way it is yeah that
would be biblical lived I mean as soon
as he came into town he deliberately did
as much as he could do to Just Cause and
slick so as much chaos as possible yeah
and you have to be you have to be you
have to watch it a couple times and you
have to be real pay close attention to
the things that he says because he says
things that set up the people in the
town he's one step ahead of him he's
manipulating them you'll see what I'm
talking about yeah if you haven't seen
the movie but yeah it's quite a cool
fluid
oh yeah I really like it and like I said
I'm not like a huge western fan but this
I would almost call this it's it's
almost like a horror movie I mean it's
kind of structured like a horror movie a
little bit and it does have a very
pretty obvious like supernatural
component I mean obviously this guy I
mean there's a scene like the the woman
that he rapes at the beginning you know
he goes back to the barber and he's
taking a bath and the barbershop because
you did that and the Old West cuz you
have bathtubs in your house I guess the
only record he hadn't even taken aback
yeah and then she enjoyed it yeah when
you see it happen because I got more
about her later
yeah but you know but then she comes
back later when he's in the tub and
tries to shoot him and he like ducks
down under the water but she clearly
shoots into that water into that water
like right at him there's no way she
could've missed yeah and then she came
with a Colt single-action army and 45
colt
and you know I've hand loaded a lot of
you know 45 ACP from 1911 s and that
load is not all that different than
bullet weights about the same you know
you know there's 10 or 20 grain
difference the velocity is similar and
that ol bullet wasn't even jacketed but
it would have killed him
45 cause there's no way she could've
there wasn't enough water she fired
several shots like into the wedding he
was only like right or anything and then
he was like that was [ __ ] up and it
was a little bitty Victorian bathtub all
the house was his damn copper bucket
really yeah you know like I did played
that whoo ya heard sound you know what I
mean that the ghost music because that
would a kid that would have killed a man
oh yeah damn he disappeared and he
totally vanishes in that little bucket
yeah so that was one thing and like I
said I've seen this three or four times
but the last time we watched it that was
one thing that I noticed that I didn't
pick up on the last time was that she
didn't miss no it wasn't like she was
just like oh I'm a girl I don't know how
to shoot a gun vanish she got him right
[ __ ] in there yes she vanished down
in he should have gotten killed should
have been killed but he wasn't he
couldn't be can he just sat up like
nothing happened like huh that was crazy
you can say that was like a horror movie
if you want to say the crow was a horror
movie really what this is this is the
crow but it's in a western setting
that's a good way of putting it yeah
it's a very similar kind of very similar
now one thing about you know that the
new breed of Sergio Leone style
spaghetti western or the new westerns
that came out of that Leone movement or
the spaghetti western movement they're a
post-apocalyptic really when you really
look at them yeah they're the Old West
kind of had an apocalyptic quality to it
and without these movies I don't think
you would have had things like Mad Max
yeah which is a post-apocalyptic movie
right you know there because if you go
back to look at Mad Max 1 & 2 there's a
lot of Western in that yeah you know a
lot of the same motifs a lot of seams
setting out in a desert you know that in
the outback
yeah instead of horses you know there's
cars yeah
but you're still dealing dealing with
the Indians and cowboys it's basically
that same thing it's just you know I do
think there's like a lot of Australian
movies that are in a similar vein is
that because they have I mean Australia
and the United States have kind of a
similar history yeah and the outback is
very much like the Old West was yet a
similar time same cars more or less you
know they're different versions of
fourth and the cultures were
similar in a hotrod cultures and gun
cultures they had all that they had
Cowboys you know yeah there's a good one
called Quigley down under which was
about a calendar that back yeah that was
a good movie
actually actually that was kind of a
recent one uh well how recent wasn't I
was a few years ago called the
proposition mmm and actually Nick Cave
wrote the screenplay for that [ __ ] that
was a Western set in Australia and it's
very very good and since its Nick Cave
it's like super super violent as you
know how that loves all that murder [ __ ]
yeah but yeah so but that's a really
good movie too but yeah so I kind of
feel like this is kind of the same cuz
this is a similar kind of thing that he
did was like Pale Rider right a rider
was came after this yeah Pale Rider is
very much the same Congress it's the
same kind of thing like pal rights you
know here cuz The Pale Rider death Rider
he is the Angel of Death right right
come to answer a young girl's prayer
yeah to save the town that's also a good
movie if you like you see this one you
like this one and you haven't seen Pale
Rider go see Pale Rider
yeah I think this one I think High
Plains Drifter is more obviously yeah
super dude like a ghost story and more
like supernatural is essentially a ghost
stories pale rider you got to pay a lot
more attention to it yeah he seems more
like a guy or like a character yeah in
Pale Rider even though obviously you
know what the symbolism is but in this
one he almost seems like cuz he doesn't
talk all that much and you never know
what his name is until the end and it's
like he's just very stoic and very like
not making any expression so he seems
almost like not non-human but like maybe
superhuman or he's devil man yeah
something like man what he is punishing
punishing the evil punishing the wicked
yeah he's very much like devil man and a
few visit which is a Japanese yeah yeah
yeah yeah I fit and another thing too
that I love about this is that how
[ __ ] pathetic are the people in this
[ __ ] town
oh they're bad it's like three okay the
three dudes ride back into town three
dudes yeah and they've been in prison
and [ __ ] like that they ride back into
town how many people are in this town at
least 40 50 40 50 dudes and they all
like guns and [ __ ] like that yeah three
guys right in
going put you deep dude in there I'll
just like [ __ ] and then they have to
stop in front oh yeah Eastwood has the
revenant trains them and equips them
with rifles and puts them in firing
positions and defensive positions up
around the town yeah he tells us what
the data help exactly what to do they
even try even gets them to practice yeah
you know pray you know and as soon as
these guys show up they just drop their
guns around yeah they're just like oh
yeah yeah I guess like that's kind of
the whole ideas that they were cowards
there showed that they were they were
getting what they deserve and then they
deserve a right and like I said yeah he
would just grab a dude's wife and say
come on let's go and the men would just
tolerate it they wouldn't even stop him
we'll see that's what happened see the
first one was very kind of obviously a
rape even though they kind of enjoyed it
halfway through um the second one they
did that was the hotel owners yeah I
forever yeah she um doctors gonna be
raping and he was like don't flatter
yourself yeah that's true and then she
was like oh all right he negged her
company true he didn't say the reason
she got mad - because her husband didn't
stick up for her yeah I think that was
kind of the point that they were making
and that was how he saved her soul
because she left her husband after all
yeah and she was the only person I mean
other than Mordechai like the door who
couldn't do anything about it he just
like crawled in and he was like
horrified by the murder because he
watched the previous marshal getting
murdered now the woman that was the
hotel wife they actually show her in the
flashback and she's like what are you
doing stomping and she saying she was
like you're crazy and all this other
kind so she did protest and she was the
only person that after it happened she
was saying you know how tragic it was
that that good man was out there without
a headstone they had been murdered oh
you know over the mining rights you know
and he's doing the right thing you know
that kind of stuff yeah so when he
grabbed her in front of the husband he
says come on I need some company said
best bottle of wine she assumed she was
gonna be raped she brings it up because
of what happened to the other girl right
and he says no no everything you just
started talking with her we don't have
sex with him anyway yeah and like I said
I think that was not consensual
yeah like the whole point of that scene
was that
was that her husband didn't say kind of
like oh well she's just gonna get yeah
he didn't even care gonna care
who cares that yeah yeah like that so
the next day she was like she packed her
bags and and then they made eye contact
he's like yeah get out here yeah it's
all good she's like yes and she was out
of here I'm like you said he's
essentially like saved her soul yeah all
that [ __ ] was met it was kind of like
metaphors for saving people's souls so
they didn't go to hell yeah Mordechai
yeah and but like I said Mordechai and
like the two Mexican if you work then
everybody [ __ ] on the studio sound [ __ ]
oh well the dwarf got [ __ ] on - yeah
it's like they would just take him
around any old Indian man in the Indian
Child
oh right right right through in the
store like he gave them a bunch of free
[ __ ] like blankets and candy and stuff
in the store that you know the store
owner was like we can't give those
Injuns anything and there's like want
anything do you would you like a young
Mex or maybe an [ __ ] girl
remember that [ __ ] yeah he goes no
that's all right he turns around to us
grabbing people's wives yeah we take
this one
yeah so he was like damn for as bad as
Network he did bad things but he did bad
things in the service of a greater he
was trying to shoot it all worked out
yeah he was trying to show them I guess
what hypocrites they were tail yeah but
yeah so if you're like even if you're
not into westerns which I'm not you
would probably like this movie because
like I said it's kind of like a ghost
story it's like the crow in the well
just like the crowd yeah except in the
Wild West in 1973 so you know if you
like that kind of thing you'll probably
like this one - like I said Clint
Eastwood's only his second directorial
if you like this one when you see it see
Pale Rider you Pale Rider yeah I
actually like this one better than Pale
Rider but Pale Rider is very good too so
check it out I like all used to his
Westers yeah yeah
Josey Wales Unforgiven I like him all
day Hank um I was an American one that
was kind of a straight white head movie
but they're still good yeah I like I
said I kind of like yellow Leone movies
with him although the only movies look
good actually I haven't seen duck you
sucker and I haven't seen once upon a
time the West I want to see those two
yeah but Tony looks good eventually
we're gonna do the whole man with no
name yeah we'll do a comment trilogy
good worth seeing those musical
and those are [ __ ] fantastic we just
saw the other day on YouTube he showed
me who was that doing that it was like
some awkward yeah it was it was like a
Finnish Orchestra I think and do it they
did all the man with no name themes yeah
awesome yeah look it up on YouTube
because it was like really good I'll I
particularly loved that they had like
the one woman and like her whole job
let's just sit there and go Leonie
rewrote the book and Eastwood ran with
it yeah Eastwood did American spaghetti
westerns it's kind of like and I think I
mentioned this when we were talking
about probably we're talking about deep
red where I talk about how the Italians
they kind of get [ __ ] on for like oh
you're ripping off Alfred Hitchcock or
you're ripping off there's no continuity
but when they make movies then the
Americans rip them back off like I'm in
the giallo movies that was like us
ripping them off that's where the whole
slasher genre Italians knew how to make
things exciting dance with a dial
astounding a stylish now Leone also had
a very good story so long yeah and we're
and good music that went with it like
the scores were really good so and it
was all just kind of coming together
yeah you know he knew he was doing yeah
Leone was like the Francis Ford Coppola
of Italian western movies yeah yeah and
honestly those movies I feel like
they're just considered classic Westerns
like not even oh because they're Italian
or American or anything like that
they're just considered classics of the
genre yeah and I feel like they're
they're usually like at the top of
anybody's list that's like into western
since yeah anybody that knows what
they're talking about anyway
are you think but yeah we see the
Coppola or do you think he was more like
the guy just shiny was his name Stanley
Kubrick yeah it Stan Kubrick that's
probably he's probably more like -
Stanley Kubrick not as weird as Stanley
Kubrick but but it yes the similar kind
of
a budding pitcher guy for the Italian
spaghetti western yeah for good quality
control yeah from based on what
everything I saw so far I have to see
those other two movies to make a final
judgment but yeah man with no name
series was every movie was good yeah
they weren't all as good as one another
I mean I think good bad the ugly was the
best of them all yeah I think would
probably agree with you on it you know a
fistful of dollars a few dollars more
they seem to be pretty good yeah they're
yeah but yeah we'll get to that like you
know we'll get to that so like I said if
even if you're not into westerns but if
you like you know creepy horror movies
or whatever then check out High Plains
Drifter it's actually a pretty cool
movie and remember if you like the show
like share subscribe on all your social
media if you'd like to financially
supports you can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
cast out wordpress comm there's a link
in the sidebar
to a PayPal account if you'd like to
have a one-time donation or perhaps a
rolling donation whatever you want to do
that's cool and it's much appreciated
remember that these movie retrospectives
right here come out every Friday and our
matinee show which is three new movies
in the theater comes out every Sunday
and our regular episodes come out every
Tuesday so check them out we will see
you next time bye